The rate is included in this line, where we calculate the interest. The
interest calculation has to happen inside the loop. Because the balance is
incremented by a different amount every year. If we moved this line out of the
loop, it would only happen once. And our interest would always be $10. Even
when we already have 100,000 in the bank. So I'll put that back. There is some
magic numbers still in this code. Maybe these should actually be named
variables. So I could take this, and make this into the target. And I can take
out the rate, and call it a rate. Now this code is much more readable. We can
see that it goes well the balance is less than the target, and the interest
increments by the balance plus the rate.